Spiritualities to experience
awareness,
which is universal,
and when we experienced that domain of
awareness,
which is beyond our skin and capsulated
eagle identities,
then we have the spontaneous
understanding of love,
compassion,
uh,
it becomes our nature not as a moral
dictate,
but something which is a natural
expression of ourselves.
It also gives us insight into the
mechanics of how intention orchestrates
its own fulfillment.
Spiritualities,
also a sense of connection with the
creative power of the universe,
the mystery that we call God a,
and by having a sense of connection to
that greater power,
we gain self esteem and have the ability
to create because we align ourselves
with the elements and forces of creative
universe.
We begin to realize that the universe is
creative,
that is conscious,
that it's evolving and our personal
evolution is somehow linked to the
evolution of the mystery that we call
them
experiential.
In
India it is trucked out to yoga,
but most people have a misunderstanding
of yoga.
They equate it with the physical
postures that they do in a yoga studio,
which are one component of yoga,
but yoga classically is divided into
four types and they have to do with four
basic instincts that human beings have,
being feeling,
thinking,
and doing.
So the yoga of being his meditation,
self reflection,
um,
the ability to shut off the world of the
sentences and go to the source of our
own thought.
It's called Raja Yoga.
Uh,
the second yoga is the Yoga of love
through relationship and understanding
that love is a,
is the ultimate truth at the heart of
creation,
and that through relationship we can
move progressively from attraction to
infatuation,
to communion,
to intimacy,
to passion,
to detachment,
to ecstasy,
which is our ground state,
the exaltation of our spirit.
So love and relationship is a second
means of experiencing spirituality.
If somebody doesn't understand
spirituality,
ask them if they've ever been in love.
That's the experience of spirituality.
That third way of understanding yoga or
having the experience of spirit is
through service.
When you perform service without any
selfish motivation,
it's called Karma Yoga.
Then you also get in touch with the same
domain of awareness that we call spirit.
And the fourth way of understanding
spirituality is,
uh,
through the intellect,
through the mind,
through science,
to understanding how the laws of nature
work.
Because the laws of nature are in fact
the mind.